I know you believe that other couples  are truly happy but the truth is they  are nobody's happy unless they're single  miss role charlie is what people are  meant to be you mind if I smoked really  why do I feel like my head is gonna  explode in a hurricane of generic  questions are you from where do you work  where did you go to school you know the  DMI better than you questions yeah well  asking this is how you know you're a New  Yorker let's go just a little robots  sniff each other's panties really yes  five orgasms Cinco gasps maybe we should  I really like you yeah quit my job today  [Music]  I'm happy leave me alone iced teas women  you look really nice I buy you a drink  how you doing oh yeah it's catchy like  the clap  [Music]  and the knowledge is never without a  price  you